this is the Battle of South foo-foo this
is the finally we get little bit of the
battle it's mostly a one-on-one but as
we know team 3e goes in and tries to
stop general Zelda in her sleep but
because she's just so frigging awesome
she knew it was coming and I loved that
she stayed true to the truce cuz I'm
waiting for her to break out know that
that's the good guys that break down
yeah no totally the good guys broke the
tree yeah no I thought that was great um
and she's just like okay all bets are
off I tried now I'm gonna take away your
kingdom sorry bitch and Korra goes in
and says you know no reason and she's
like you broke the truce I'm going in
but I'm so nice I'm such a cool general
I will give you another chance I will
fight the goddamn avatar because I am
the cool villain the show's ever had and
I'll make a deal and you know I'll stick
to it guys stick to it before if you win
I'll go away I'll be happy just my
billions of armies and people as double
will take over the world I don't know
but I'm that confident a jail prisoner
will be quiet no joy but if I'm right if
you go down
I'm gonna Herot millions of registered
voters
there'll be no voting in my empire so
yeah it makes it all there will be
education yeah education camps so makes
you offer to Korra that if she beats her
she'll go away and if not she gets the
town Chora agrees Lobby having their
battle Varrick blows himself up very
very slowly and very awesomely so many
good lines in this episode yeah you're
insane you knew that when you hired me I
anything with Vericut there's a lot of
Barrick in this ant in this really
intense moment the thing with the remote
well if you were gonna blow yourself up
anyway what do you need to run me out of
the Train which I would use anyway but
I'm still here
but then you're going to take me outside
I mean wonderful blend of really good
suspense and comedy and again holding a
very I just I hate you so so bake it out
okay but I think verax dead avatar core
is about to defeat the general she's in
the Avatar state about to smash her with
a rock but suddenly she has her Empire
Strikes Back moment again and she's like
well put the poisons out what the hell
falls to the ground
Zelda rocks her up and the snow the
rocks the air and the kids pretty much
save her you know it's got like got my
avatar no no it's like okay with egg and
got captured all the time like that was
his thing like core losses all the time
losing bono car you think you're just
gonna go in and fight kuvira when you're
all rusty you're gonna have a bad time
so but they get her out and they're
wondering what went wrong there and now
so that has the whole she pretty much
has the earth Kingdom and Julie is now
gonna try and create the ultimate holy
shit Spirit Bomb and kept us where we
last left off um great episode I the
only thing I was thinking maybe we would
get but I'm calm okay we didn't is like
the big lor the Rings battle because you
have you know Mordor lined up there and
you keep things are gonna march in its
up I liked for one-on-one games you
forgetting something here that would
cost money money that Nickelodeon's
probably not willing to spin its but no
it's I think these seasons do look
beautiful as much we like to know no
it's it's that it's like they're the
only small yeah that's look unbelievable
yeah the only thing that sticks out is
the CG on there the little Mick warriors
they're gonna now but apart from that
it's really gorgeous yeah and there's a
lot of air Guinea which like I said I
love it's good blend of comedy and
in really intense moments - I was
actually kind of like what's gonna
happen is the bomb really on is it not
really odd um and like I say it's a mono
e mono and anything that just makes
general Zelda look more awesome and
varrick look more awesome
I'm totally work Marik I'm sorry Gert
but anything that made of alchemy I
don't care but the fancy hair so yeah I
think the only thing the only question I
have for you before you say your opinion
is do you think Julie do you think this
is all still just part of like a ruse
like she's still absolutely I think so
too I don't know it's a touch blondie I
like but I will say if it isn't that's
the twist yeah cuz it seems like they're
still kind of building that up but yeah
I'd be shocked if it wasn't I'm 90%
certain that this is all a big ruse on
her part and she's still gonna be a good
guy at the end but then the real
question is a very keen on it is he just
putting up an act this whole time even
for Belen nobody was dreaming I myself
had to Bolin was in the I know I don't
fit my guess would be verax about it of
it because that would be a nice little
revenge for I think Julie's how do I put
this I think Juhi her feelings are real
in that she's just frickin sick of Eric
but I think that this is also part of a
ruse so if she gets to do this ruse and
also make Varrick think that he's been
betrayed like extra bonus for her like
that's just the icing on the cake to
annoy him as well if that makes any
sense
mm-hm but yeah well your I don't know I
just it was a really solid episode that
most of it was the lines and the writing
I you know you can't take all this me
well and the whole bit with the two
pictures oh he loves verses in it I love
it to himself it's like an emperor and
like this great yeah at the very end
Susan hey get your hands off me you're
crushing my individuality
yeah all of the Varrick lines just
really was probably one of the most
funniest written episode
for these kind of lines that they threw
in and yet it was still so freakin
intense yeah and we so when you think
about nothing much is really going on
it's the two are it's one scenario where
the two are fighting in another scenario
where they're debating whether or not
this bomb is gonna go off and that's
really about it
but both those situations they did them
so well they kind of do I like that
kuvira is a master of diplomacy here
because she pretty like my guess is she
predicted all of this was gonna happen
like she's like don't break the truce
and then I look like a good guy yeah
like it seems to me I mean she obviously
particular was gonna happen because it
was jus me in the bed instead of her so
like all of this felt right into her
plan like I don't know if she thought
she really could defeat the avatar it
looked you know every the people dumped
on the avatar a little air Korra too
much like I I read a great description
and that somebody's sent to me and
they're just like you know what if she
had one ever be like oh yeah she doesn't
have to go through any difficult trials
and tribulations you just pick this up
again so easily and if she had lost well
as she did or is like oh well she just
sucks I mean she can't do anything worst
avatar ever so it's like really if you
look at it she got really close to it it
was tough but she pulled herself up and
by the end of it she was really close to
winning now see to me it's more of that
like if it just happened this season
like I'd be fine and I really like this
she kept the diplomacy - she's like if I
go in it's only gonna make things where
it's like the old core I would have done
that so I like that but it's one of
those things to where it's like we just
seem to lose so much I mean like if it
only happened once in a while you know
I'd be okay but it just happened to so
much that's whywe happens again so like
yeah well okay we we say that but she's
really the only time she's come up in
the negative was this past season
otherway she's come out ahead
no I mean it's worked out but it's
always like how do I put I like sit with
but I would both avatars there is always
a somebody has to say this somebody
always has to save Aang from like
getting capture break out the cell or
something like that and someone always
has to save Korra from like a fight or
she's falling or something like that so
it's like
Pollak team avatar it's just well there
you go speaking of which man we really
haven't seen my co in a while happily I
just love to think that in the middle of
this battle he's like you know giving
the earth Prince a pedicure is a big
like just cut away to him just like
Christ I hate my life
it's horrible to him and well well we
did see what to name the last episode
but it's like yet there's not that much
of them and horrible to say it's I'm
kind of okay with it like they weren't
necessarily bad characters but it's like
I like the character surprise I miss
Asami more than I miss Marco yeah I
don't know what that another interesting
thing I mean did you notice that in this
big Lord of the Rings sort of battle
ended yeah you're gonna fight me one I
want in this met all chicks mm I mean if
you look at the female-to-male quotients
and the battle in this one you know
you've got beifong you've got kuvira
you've got Korra you've got Tenzin's two
daughters and like I was like wow there
was a you know represent ya know it's
mostly women but ya know it's AI think
of anything else I do that I do think
now that they've progressed kuvira
enough yeah I think the people who
originally saying she's more communist
thick or actually correct like at first
I thought maybe they were going nazi
with her but now I'm just like oh reason
cams redistributing wealth I'm like this
is like Leninist Stalinist Mao
yeah I guess I'm not getting his nuts in
like the speech she gave at the end of
this episode in particular I'm like oh
that's where you're going with this okay
it seems more like communist
dictatorship than like fascist
dictatorship so but no I did I thought
was really solid I don't know how many
episodes we have left but but I am
probably near the halfway point and I
usually I say maybe even further
this was 13 episodes of season 12
something like that Wow if we're only
halfway that'd be great
yeah it's like I feel like we're getting
close to the end of the fact there's so
much more just makes me really excited
for it so um I know I feel bad because
now we're at the last season and I
couldn't be more psyched for this damn
show and yeah now it's over yeah I think
the creator's mentioned somewhere that
it's over oh yeah this is it so there
may be there may be like manga or
graphic novels or whatever but did ya
thinking like oh maybe we'll do some
next season wait now this is it so so
what did what did you think of her
seeing her face though like what is it
gonna be or what I don't know I mean
it's the only thing I can figure it's
like it's not the poison it's
psychological yeah that's what I thought
I thought she's seeing herself in kuvira
that's similar yeah they were sort of
drive to kick ass yeah they're both sort
of pushy you know like no no this is
what I want I know it's right no no no
are you gonna just I'm right well in
then chorus said I swore she said
someone in earlier episode she reminds
me of me there is something like that or
you know that's what the old me would
used to do so the kuvera's like the old
her so it's like yeah the new her
fighting the old her so I don't know if
it was like that scene in Empire Strikes
Back when we chops off the fake Vader's
head he sees his own face and the final
battle was very psychological unless I
came to first split second like it took
me a second to realize what we were
looking at I didn't realize I thought
she was too the Avatar State
and I'm like I didn't realize it was
Korres face I'm like oh fuck there's
another avatar running around like and
when I started to realize it was just
cause I'm like oh that would have been
so awesome I would have been like so
many question would have been raised but
yeah but I still thought it was good so
yeah no this is really sucky there's not
a lot of complaint it's really good it's
just a good season it's a good you know
it may be a sense it's a good thing as
the final season cuz it's a good one
means I get sending out a good final
note there definitely if they keep this
up all the way to the very end like
that's the thing is some of the other
seasons like I thought season one in
particular was pretty good up until the
last five minutes so if they keep this
all the way to the last second and that
just the last five minutes then yeah
they're gonna go out on top yeah no I'll
definitely be a strong season so yeah
guys that's about it uh we'll see you
next V one take care